we're in Australia and I was like
sitting in my room in the Four Seasons
with the
the view of oh that's right you had that
insane view exactly so not only the
opera house but I also saw the entire
Harbor oh as well which includes the
port for the cruise ships and the little
boy and you came out like your pupils
diet lady like whoa that's a big bowl
yeah let's see look at the boat Kelsey
look at the boat look at the boat baby
stand on the balcony with your dick out
that's a big ball wow baby look at the
boat just talking on your [__] nuts
and dick you're wearing a shirt you know
Cody put on your underwear someone else
go see the boat
[Music]